THEY ARE GIANTS AND WE NEED TO
HAVE A PUBLIC POLICY RESPONSE.
>> TUCKER: THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
ONE OF THE ACCOUNTS ON TWITTER
THAT WE JUST LEARNED WAS SHADOW
BANNED VERY AGGRESSIVELY WAS AN
ACCOUNT CALLED LIBS OF TIK TOK.
THERE IS A REASON THEY CENSORED
IT BECAUSE IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ACCOUNTS ON TWITTER.
THERE ARE VERY FEW OPINIONS
EXPRESSED ON THIS TWITTER FEED.
IT'S ALMOST ENTIRELY VIDEO, REAL
VIDEO, NO ONE DISPUTES THAT IT'S
REAL, SHOWING WHAT'S HAPPENING
INSIDE CLASSROOMS, WHERE YOUR
CHILDREN ARE BEING TAUGHT,
HOSPITALS, WHERE YOUR LOVED ONES
ARE BEING TREATED ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
SO TWITTER, ON THE BASIS OF WHAT
JUSTIFICATION, NONE, PREVENTED
LIBS OF TIK TOK FROM TRENDING.
THAT MEANS MANY PEOPLE NEVER SAW
WHAT THEY POSTED.
ACCORDING TO WEISS, AFTER THEIR
SUSPENSION, ADMITTED THAT THE
ACCOUNT OF TIK TOK WAS NOT
BREAKING ANY RULE.
THE MEMO SAID THIS.
"ACKNOWLEDGED THAT LIBS OF TIK
TOK IS NOT ENGAGED IN VIOLATIVE
HATE.
CONDUCT POLICY."
THEY DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WRONG
BUT TWITTER CENSORS KEPT
CENSORING AND SHADOWING THE
ACCOUNT OF LIBS OF TIK TOK
ANYWAY.
BECAUSE ACCORDING TO THE MEMO,
IT EITHER LEADS TO OR INTENDS TO
INCITE HARASSMENT SPECIFICALLY
AGAINST HOSPITALS THAT ARE
CASTRATING THE CHILDREN.
THAT MEMO WAS PREPARED BY THE
TWITTER SENIOR LEADERSHIP.
THE PERSON WHO RUNS LIBS OF TIK
TOK JOINS US NOW BY PHONE.
>> I SURE APPRECIATE YOU COMING
ON.
YOU MUST HAVE HAD SOME SENSE
THAT YOU WERE BEING -- YOU WERE
SUSPENDED MULTIPLE TIMES, BUT
YOU ARE BEING CENSORED IN WAYS
THEY WEREN'T TELLING YOU.
DID YOU SENSE THIS WAS
HAPPENING?
>> HI, TUCKER, GREAT TO BE BACK.
YES, I ABSOLUTELY KNEW I WAS
BEING CENSORED.
I HAD A VERY LARGE ACCOUNT.
I NEVER WAS ABLE TO TREND, AND
NOW WE FIND OUT I WAS ON THE
TREND BLACKLIST.
THERE WERE SOMETIMES DAYS OR
WEEKS AT A TIME WHERE I FELT
LIKE MY TWEETS WERE GETTING MUCH
LESS ENGAGEMENT THAN USUAL, THAN
THEY SHOULD.
NOW IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE WAS
SUPPRESSION AND SHADOW BANNING.
>> TUCKER: WHAT'S SO INFURIATING
ABOUT THIS SPECIFIC EXAMPLE IS
THAT YOU WERE REPORTING, I MEAN,
YOU WEREN'T -- OUR VIEWERS CAN
VERIFY THIS FOR THEMSELVES, IF
THEY JUST GO ON YOUR ACCOUNT,
YOU'RE NOT ACTUALLY PUTTING A
LOT OF YOUR OWN VIEWS IN HERE,
YOU WERE DISSEMINATING REPORTED
MATERIAL WHOSE AUTHENTICITY NO
ONE DOUBTS.
SO YOU'RE DOING WHAT THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" CLAIMS IT DOES BUT
YOU'RE ACTUALLY DOING IT UNLIKE
THEM.
WHAT COULD POSSIBLY BE THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR CENSORING YOU?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT
THEIR VIEWS, THEY DON'T STAND UP
TO SCRUTINY, AND WHEN I SPREAD
THEIR VIEWS IN THEIR OWN WORDS,
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO SEE IT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T STAND UP TO
SCRUTINY, AND IT MAKES THEM LOOK
BAD AND THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
REALLY SCARED OF.
AND THE CRAZIEST PART OF THIS
WHOLE THING IS, THAT THEY
ADMITTED, THAT I'M NOT EVEN
VIOLATING THE POLICIES, AND THEY
STILL SUSPENDED ME SEVEN TIMES.
SEVEN TIMES, THREE OF WHICH WERE
FOR A WEEK AT A TIME, I WAS
SUSPENDED FOR PROBABLY A MONTH
ALTOGETHER FOR WHAT?
NOT EVEN VIOLATING THEIR
POLICIES JUST BECAUSE THEY DON'T
LIKE THEIR OWN VIEWS.
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO SEE IT.
>> TUCKER: THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THEY WERE HIDING AND YOU EXPOS